[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number 193 I am Dr
Brett Weinstein you are Dr Heather Hing
I am still recovering from what was a
very unpleasant case of Co which I am
hoping to Stave off the coughs that are
dogging me even almost a couple weeks
out here
um I will just say because obviously
this is relevant uh for people who've
been following our trajectory I did take
hydroxy chloroquin and icin when I got
sick with coid um I it's been a long
time since you've been on uh itin
prophylactically a long time it just was
unsustainable because I mean in addition
to it not being good for you to be on
any drug permanently um they made it
very hard to get and so one had to judge
your ability to respond to a case of
coid rather than prevent one um so I
wasn't on it prophylactically but I did
take it um it did not uh save me from a
very unpleasant case I think it probably
did radically shorten that case it was
literally two very bad days and then
what I have left
over is I think just the damage when you
get sick with a virus it invades cells
those cells then get attacked and
destroyed by your immune system and so
it leaves wounds and the we call those
wounds lesions so anyway I believe I
just have lesions in my lungs that are
taking time to heal and they're
sensitive but and let me say that um I
mean everyone knows themselves best and
uh everyone will have some part of their
body that will tend to get affected
right with with illness like oh you know
your your brother gets this you get this
and you you um tend to have things go to
your lungs um presumably uh related to
early damage um that was from asthma
that was attributed to seasonal
allergies and uh and no doubt wheat a
much later in life Discovery and um it's
unclear you know why why those those
existed at all um given that uh there is
no reason to think uh that our ancestors
pre say Industrial Revolution were
experiencing such um such absurd
lifelong effects uh right um but you
know when when you get sick it's your
lungs that get hit and this is a disease
that is particularly um apt to go to
your lungs and so uh I think you're
dealing with u these lingering After
Effects possibly secondary infection at
this point as well yeah um let me just
say the
uh I I do have seasonal allergies I
don't think they strongly contributed to
my lung sensitivity but I do have lung
sensitivity that comes from literally
Decades of what was more or less a
constant state of inflammation that I
now know was the result of my consuming
wheat which is um something I am
exquisitly sensitive to so anyway that
does put me in a situation where as long
as I'm in good shape things are fine but
it's very easy for me to be knocked into
uh a spiral where inflammation causes
more inflammation and it's hard to get
out of
indeed okay so today we are going to
um we're going to talk about the
mainstream media a little bit and um and
about
um some safe and effective treatments
that exist out there they so we are told
and uh and oh let's see medical
gaslighting that's another topic of
conversation for Today medical
gaslighting that's a very brought to you
by fizer I kid you not very efficient
description of a very powerful force in
the universe yes yes indeed um but we so
we are coming to you from Rumble and we
encourage you to come join us there and
and join the watch party on locals we'll
also have a private Q&A on locals
tomorrow and um lots lots we've we've
been doing some impromptu amas on locals
please join us there uh we're going to
drop everything else that we would like
to encourage you to to join us at until
the end with the exception of our three
awesome sponsors our three sponsors this
week are mudwater paleo Valley Hillsdale
College and uh I am going to read those
ads now without further Ado all right
our first sponsor this week is m water
which makes truly delicious products mud
water makes a fantastic drink it's spicy
and delicious and chalk full of
adaptogenic mushrooms and atic herbs
with 17th of caffeine as a cup of coffee
you get energy without the anxiety
Jitters or crash of coffee if you like
the routine of making and drinking a cup
of warmth in the morning but don't drink
coffee or trying to cut down try mud
water if you're looking for a different
way to kick off your day with a
delicious warming enhancing way that
isn't just a caffeine Rush dry mud water
each ingredient was added with intention
it has cacao and chai for just a hint of
caffeine Lion's main mushrooms to
support Focus Corps to help support
physical performance Shaga and RI to
support your immune system cinnamon
which is a potent ant antioxidant and
more mud water also makes a non-dairy
creamer out of coconut milk and MCT and
a sweetener out of coconut palm sugar
and Luma the fruit and an andian tree
used by the Inca to add if you prefer
those options Zach has been drinking a
lot of mud water lately in fact um I'll
I'll I'll go into the kitchen and find
him drinking it morning noon and night
they've got a a nighttime um a nighttime
product that doesn't include any
caffeine and you've been enjoying it
quite a lot he's got a drinking solution
he's got a drinking
Solution that's good um you can mix a
match add a bit of their coconut milk
and MCT creamer with some honey from
bees or use mudat Luma and coconut palm
sugar sweetener and skip the bees
entirely mudw water is also 100% USDA
organic non-GMO gluten-free vegan and
kosher certified mud water's flavor is
warm and spicy with a hint of chocolate
plus Masala chai which includes Ginger
and cardamom nutmeg and cloves it's also
delicious blend it into a smoothie try
it with banana and Ice milk or milk-like
substance if you insist mint a touch of
honey and cacao nibs to get 15% off go
to mudwater docomo horod to support the
show use code darkos darkos darkos no no
no no the one hos the Dark Horse pod for
15% off at mudwater that's mud wt.com
all right try this drink mud water until
the caca come home
yeah okay right and then even after they
do right keep drinking it but you know
one step at a time is basically that's
the drinking Solution that's okay
excellent our second sponsor this week
is Paleo Valley paleo Valley makes a
huge range of products from supplements
like fish row and organ complex
grass-fed bone broth protein and
superfood bars everything we've tried
from them has been terrific including
their golden milk made with loads of
turmeric but we're going to talk again
today about their beef sticks the beef
in these delicious snacks come from
small American-owned Farms that practice
rotational grazing paleo Valley's beef
sticks are 100% grass-fed and finished
entirely organic and naturally fermented
100% grass-fed beef is more nutritious
than grin fed beef in many ways
including that it contains more calcium
magnesium potassium zinc phosphorus beta
carotene and iron and it's also utterly
delicious if you're thinking that paleo
Valley's beef sticks are like slim gems
you're wrong for one thing unlike slim
gems paleo Valley beef sticks contain no
mechanically separated chicken parts for
another paleo Val's beef sticks are
actually good for you ingredients hiding
in most beef sticks and jerky include
MSG hormones hydrogenated oils and
brominated vegetable oil which if you're
wondering what that is was first
patented as a flame retardant and now
it's in a lot of food not if you buy
paleo valley though furthermore unlike
other meat snacks paleo Valley uses
natural fermentation to preserve its
beef sticks this gives the beef sticks a
long shelf life without the use of
harmful acids and chemicals and with the
added benefit of contributing to a
healthy gut paleo valy beef sticks are
also keto friendly and make a great
protein Rich snack to grab when you're
on the go like running running out the
door for a meeting or going on a bike
ride paleo Valley does not cut Corners
they sourice only the highest quality
ingredients and are passionate not only
about human health but environmental
restoration and Animal Welfare as well
and they're a family-owned company try
paleo Valley's beef sticks today you'll
be so glad that you did head over to
paleo val.com Darkhorse for 15% off of
your first
order I'm I'm trying to help I just you
know how it is you're
good our final sponsor this week at some
point I will have Brett begin to read
ads again and then um and then we can
get back I'm going to whistle at you the
hilarity of
Dyslexia yeah our final sponsor this
week is Hillsdale College if you are a
few years or decades out of school
thinking back and wondering what you
learned you're not alone maybe you wish
you had taken more time to study topics
that would be more meaningful to you
something lasting and profound if so
you're not alone and it's not too late
since 1844 Hillsdale College has been
providing an education that focuses on
freedom and character because they
believe that a virtuous citizen is the
best defense for Liberty and now they've
taken some of their core classes and
made them available online for free for
anyone who wants to learn timeing
technology have changed a lot of things
but they have not changed basic
fundamental truths about the world and
our place in it Hillsdale colleges
online courses range widely there are
several on the constitution on Congress
the presidency and the Supreme Court
there are great books courses as well as
courses focusing on the works of CS
Lewis Mark Twain Shakespeare and Jane
Austin they history classes from ancient
Christianity to the R and fall of the
Roman Republic to the second world war
and even classes on math and logic from
euklid to Modern geometry and one of the
great principles of
chemistry over three over three million
people have taken a Hillsdale College
online course you could be next there
are 39 free courses to choose from the
self-paced you can start whenever you
want in fact you can start right now
wait till after the podcast it's
everything you need all in one place
with no long-term commitment learn when
and where you want enroll now in
Hillsdale is not for credit online
courses program it's free it's it's fun
and it will change the way you
understand our country the world and
your place in it go right now to
hillsdale.edu Darkhorse to enroll
there's no cost and it's easy to get
started that's hillsdale.edu Darkhorse
to register once again hillsdale.edu
Darkhorse get smarter it's way
cool pretty cool no it's way cool
smarter me come on what doesn't it help
with I think pretty much everything I
don't know maybe not swimming no I even
swimming I don't know why I came up with
that I feel like it probably helps with
everything it does help with everything
but you going to apply it carefully
right so um smarter doesn't mean
constantly being in the conscious mind
oh totally right no um so uh you need to
smarter means figuring out when to move
stuff up or into the cultural layer to
use um the framework that we introduce
in hun gatherers guide of the 21st
century and let things go yeah let let
you know let let your unconscious mind
lead the way when you're doing something
something like for instance swimming if
you're a very good swimmer or playing a
sport
or gosh an especially physical
activities that are somewhat complex in
terms of uh what you need to do see
that's wisdom which is pretty damn smart
yeah okay all
right I feel like you're conflating some
things but okay okay but productively I
mean that's I mean that's kind of what
we
do okay so um
sorry I just feel that I just you know
it's it's the um the triggering of the
feelings that maybe you've married the
wrong person that I I hate to uh you
feel like you've married the wrong
person no no I feel like I'm triggering
those feelings in you no idea what's
happening okay I'm trying to help you
I'm trying to protect you from doing a
lot of talking and I'd rather you just
talk no no I'm going to I'm going to I'm
going to allow you to help me let's just
see how that goes okay
um this has been a very weird well era
right um but it feels like things are
ramping up and at least in the US this
could easily be attributable to uh the
presidential election that's still it's
still you know 14 months away but uh no
13 months away at this point you know
still um but it feels like the middle
ground scramble uh which we have talked
about uh a lot
is is reupping reconfiguring uh those
who might have been chosen to be in uh
you know the anointed ones um are
shifting slightly and there are are new
people who are sort of ascending while
again those who have insisted on saying
actually just because you have the
degree just because you have the
authority the job the credential the
platform does not mean that you are
right because you're going to have to to
give us some insight into how it is that
you came to the conclusions that you
came to uh and instead we're
seeing almost every place in the
mainstream media is just doubling down
on their absurdity and I guess we wanted
to pick three such platforms this week
to talk about just a little bit can I
introduce one thing there that I think
uh
people it's very hard to understand what
actually goes on in American politics
but here's a hint um that will explain
why even 14 months out from a
presidential election it feels
like somebody uh put LSD in the water um
the way the American electoral system
works the useful choices have to be
eliminated from the battle uh from the
ballot in the primary that's how the the
trick is done and so the idea that we're
14 months out is actually um
not an accurate representation because
the game is being actively played
because at the moment there are some
real threats that are on the map still
primaries began early in 2024 right and
so whatever is being arranged is being
arranged so that the tripping and the
falling and the no longer being a viable
candidate will be long since done at the
point that the uh general election
really ramps up now I will point out um
whatever else you think of
Trump trump proved that the general
election is not completely fixed right
by fixed I don't necessarily mean ballot
stuffing but I mean whatever the level
of control is that one needs to
guarantee an outcome in the he got in
even though the power players in the
Republican Party didn't want him in he
played them yeah and um I've said it
many many times I mean it uh I am not a
fan of trump I don't believe that a guy
with that temperament belongs in that
office but he did the country a huge
favor in proving that that last step at
least when he accomplished this was not
fully locked up and so that also makes
the primaries much more interesting
because if one can escape through the
primaries in a viable position it means
that there is at least something to be
discussed as to what will happen in the
general election so anyway I am
expecting things to go absolutely
haywired over the next 14 months and I'm
not expecting it to be a slow ramp up
because I know a large fraction of the
game is much earlier than we tend to
think yes no that's that's absolutely
right and that fits very well with um
the cover of Harpers this month you can
show my screen here Zach um Harper
magazine one of what has been one of the
great uh magazines in in the United
States uh Harper craving a choice
Insurgency and its threat to the
Democratic party and they have pictures
of Maran
Williamson Robert F Kennedy and Cornell
West as if they are the threat to the
Democratic party and of course they are
no threat to the Democratic party the
threat to the Democratic party is the
Democratic party itself the Democrats
have um have gone off the rails and uh
and are not making any sense at all can
I add something sure if that cover go
back to the cover
Zach if that cover instead of saying
Insurgency and it's threat to the
Democratic party said Insurgency and its
threat to the DNC then this would
actually be an accurate cover because
that's really the game and this is
another place where people need to be
very careful to think through some
subtle distinctions the Democratic party
is a couple things it's a power
structure largely I don't even know that
it's housed in the DNC but the DNC is
the um the visible piece of it
and then there are the rank and file and
those are two different things and the
problem the reason that these folks are
a threat to the DNC is that they
actually do resonate with a large piece
of the rank and file which the DNC is
trying to undo and by using Harpers to
portray them as a threat to the
Democratic party it inverts reality and
it uh basically synonymize the dnc's
interest with that of the um the rank
and file which is the opposite of the
truth the DNC is uh a cabal that
conspires to prevent the Democratic
Party from serving the interests of the
democratic party voters and the
citizenry of the country yeah now I I
sort of Imagine a
uh you know Avatar of the DNC coming to
the voters uh and saying well but you
know you're
a you're a Democrat aren't you you have
to vote for us you're a Democrat aren't
you
uh to which all
awake Democratic or formally Democratic
voters should say well it's not me who's
changed you're no longer a Democrat
you're no longer acting in the way um
that we were
told the Democratic party was acting now
to what extent has that been going on
all along when did things start to
change uh these are important questions
but uh certainly at this point craving a
choice Insurgency and its threat to the
DNC as you say is a more accurate
description so I just um I want to read
and you I've just got the hard copy here
because you know we still we still
subscribe the Harpers and the Atlantic
and the New York Times and in part it's
important to see but these you know
bastions of what were once uh journalism
uh still have to say uh and in part it's
I guess um Nostalgia honestly um here we
go from the cover story of this craving
a choice Insurgency and its threat to
the Democratic party in the October 2023
edition of Harpers the establ The
Establishment response has been
predictably unwelcoming Williamson who
we all remember uh ran uh last time as
well was ubiquitously derided during the
2020 campaign as Kookie and allbit loopy
snear that have followed her into her
second run she nurses bitter feelings of
her treatment as an outsider intruding
in a professional politician's playing
field especially during the 2020
Democratic debates every time I saw Amy
Kuchar I don't know if that's how you
pronounce her name that he pronounce her
name I think that's her okay every time
I saw Amy clabar this is uh Williamson
talking she would say to me are you
having fun that was all she ever said
Williamson told me every time I saw Pete
budage is that how you pronounce his
name okay I only ever read these names I
never listen um every time I see I saw
Pete bued he said are you having fun yet
I didn't realize how much like high
school the whole thing would be
Williamson says okay so that's the
that's something on Williamson here
pointing out um that she was treated as
the weird kid who didn't really belong
there uh like uh but and the some of the
rest of the contenders in 2020 anyway uh
acted like Mean Girls later in this
article uh this is with regard to
Kennedy but it is his vociferous
denunciation of the pharmaceutical
industry that has evoked the most
fevered response among Democratic party
stalwarts an onslaught repeat an
onslaught replat with character iations
of him as crazy and
unhinged Kennedy's platform is replete
with disperate positions such as pledges
on the core Progressive issue to support
Environmental Protections a deference to
the Second Amendment and a demand that
the southern border be made
impervious so just take for a moment the
idea that these
are disperate positions these are
disperate positions if you hold that the
only non- disperate position is to abide
by the platform set up over here by the
Democrats or the platform set up over
here by the Republicans in which case uh
sure supporting Environmental
Protections would seem to be the thing
that the left that the Democrats have
claimed as their own but there are
plenty of people interested in
protecting the environment on the right
they just aren't interested in doing it
the same way as those on the left uh
Defence to the Second Amendment again
seems to be something established as
what people on the right care about but
there are plenty of people on the left
who understand that it is an important
part of our
Constitution and the a demand that the
southern border be made
impervious I remember when everyone
understood that if there are going to be
nation states in the world there are
going to be borders so that doesn't yes
that has become polarizing it has become
political but the idea that these are
inherently disperate positions is
ludicrous right in
fact I don't know how much people are
paying attention to what's going on the
southern border but it is
so uh paradoxical and it reveals the um
the farce that uh our system of
governance has become to have
effectively an unchecked flood of people
carrying who knows what across our
Southern border while we still pretend
at other borders and even at the
checkpoints on the southern border um to
be a nation in which we are very careful
about who and what we allow in so right
this is some kind of theater yes have
you you flown in or or come in over land
or by boat uh to the United States at
any point in the last 10 anytime since
9911 really but even even before that we
pretend to be extraordinarily careful
yeah and it just there's no logical
sense to be made of it because the
chances that those who have um ill
intent towards us the chances that they
will notice that whatever it is that
they wish to bring in or whoever it is
that they wish to bring in could be uh
spirited across the southern border and
then taken by bus to the
interior of the country the chances that
they will notice that is 100%
so um what are we doing and I would just
finally say what I do not hear discussed
at all in that
context is what it says about Trump and
his wall right I've heard people mention
the wall and say well they were
tunneling under it with sophisticated
technology I believe that's true maybe a
wall is insufficient
but it certainly it was ineffective is
quite different from the Hue and cry
over it's racist and barbaric well
ineffective you know I would rather have
a wall that somebody has figured out how
to go under where all I have to do is
figure out where somebody's invested
$100,000 or half a million dollars to go
under the wall that's going to be a lot
easier to plug the leaks in that system
than one where you literally have uh no
barrier you have have uh people who are
supposed to be enforcing the law at the
border who are actually facilitating the
flow so anyway I there's a part of me
that sees
the stupidity over on the blue team as
having understood that Trump was the
enemy any thought he had was the inverse
of true that's right what is the
opposite of a wall except for
vaccines well that's a whole different
topic but if the idea is well because
Trump said wall wall is obviously the
inverse of the right answer therefore
the right answer is a funnel right
well how that should be Biden's
campaign's looking build the funnel
build the funnel right it it couldn't
conceivably make less sense and the idea
that we are having some sort of a debate
about well is there really an invasion
going on on the southern border and you
know you know Elon Musk has to go down
there and wear a cowboy hat and
investigate it himself in order what now
musk went to the Border okay um he went
to the border and he talked to um to
border patrol agents for himself yeah
okay and because he's Elon Musk he can
where most of us would not be able to go
in and be like and border patrol talk to
me no he he was able to do it because he
was Elon but you know um we've had
invites we've had no availability but
it's not hard apparently to go observe
this yeah we we also have greater access
than those people true um but anyway
something uh um totally bizarre that is
a complete indictment of whatever it is
that's allow I mean you know if it was
incompetence in the executive branch
that was allowing this to happen that
would in and of itself be an indicator
that these people cannot be left in
office if it was incompetence and it
obviously isn't it's obviously orders
yeah so what the hell is that what the
hell is that okay two more things from
this uh this Atlantic cover uh sorry
Harper's cover story from October
2023 uh in which which they blame uh the
failure of the democratic party on
Marian Williamson RFK Jr and Cornell
West nevertheless the bulk of Kennedy's
positions fit the mold of what used to
pass for a liberal Democrat a sailing
corporate power the military-industrial
complex Foreign Wars and censorship
positions implicitly abandoned by an
Administration that is committed to the
Ukraine war and increased military
spending sounds like the Harpers of Y
doesn't it why are liberals now in
support of War he lamented to the Wall
Street Journal why are they suddenly in
support of censorship why are liberals
suddenly putting Faith ultimate faith in
pharmaceutical companies who have always
been great villains in the liberal
Zeitgeist fantastic yes but these
questions are going to remain unanswered
so Kudos tiny bit to uh harbers for
putting that paragraph in here um but
isn't it time for all of the people who
insist that they are Democrats now
because they've always been Democrats to
wake up to the fact that that word no
longer means what it used to mean
and that uh supporting what is currently
leading the Democratic party means
supporting you know almost entirely the
opposite of what you thought you were
supporting in times past and it's not
that this sort of thing hasn't happened
before of course political parties
change dramatically and presumably you
most people don't know at the time that
it is happening because it's useful for
the parties to hold on to the the voters
that they had before
but really sealing corporate power the
military-industrial complex Foreign Wars
and
censorship that's what the Democratic
party supposedly stood for and it stands
for none of these things now so the the
irony here is that this is very simply
explained by an obvious hypothesis which
is capture yeah that something has taken
control of the democratic party but BR
capture sounds that consp iracy sure
does um and apparently you don't think
people were colluding do you uh it's
hard to imagine that people could ever
collude I know but I've never known if
we can take that one Leap and imagine
that people may sometimes collude which
is to say talking about things that
other people don't want them talking
about is that basically what collusion
is um yes to uh to agree to participate
in an attempt to accomplish something
while cloaking the fact that that is
being attempted how dare they
um if if that is even such a thing that
I don't even know if it's possible in
humans I mean baboon maybe but probably
not humans but anyway I mean look okay
you got the Democratic party it is now
um taken up arms against every value
that it held uh when you and I were were
kids yeah right all of those things are
now enemy values and what is fueling its
continued power is effectively
Allegiance Nostalgia allegiance to a
color the fact that people have been
trained to watch blue right blue feels
like a breath of fresh air red feels
like the enemy voters who have that view
who look at the New York Times and think
of it as a pretty good source of
information they look at the font they
look at the presentation right the
Atlantic they feel like I'm in good
hands right all of these things are
positions that historically meant
something but if something were to be
captured and you know I'm getting sick I
need I need a better analogy than this
because this one's getting old but there
is a dog it has a nature it's your
family dog it's lovely it rolls over and
gets its belly scratched one day it gets
rabies everything that you think about
your dog needs to go out the window
that's not your dog anymore it's been
commandeered by something that is deadly
and what we have is a party it has not
always been a good party it was a party
of racism and Jim Crow right but it has
also historically been a party of
working people a party that advocated
for their interests and that was a
natural winner yeah right how could it
not
be that party has now adopted positions
that are absolutely hostile to the
well-being of almost all American
citizens capture is the obvious
explanation for it and the reason that
that does not instantly cause people to
recoil has to do with habit and
Nostalgia and uh loyalty to um something
that existed in the past for which there
is no evidence in the Pres
present and it also
um it's not an actionable conclusion it
leaves people feeling hopeless and I and
I do feel like um I am sensing a a
greater ever greater sense um again of
hopelessness you know there have been
there have been moments and movements in
the last three and a half years now in
which there was hope and you know I
think I think the moment that seemed the
highest to me was during the uh trucker
Convoy in Canada in early 2022 this
would have been
um the desire to to sweep it all under
the rug and to pretend that the people
who were who were
being duplicitous cruel
authoritarian sometimes evil uh were not
doing that they were maybe they were
misled maybe it turns out they were
wrong maybe not um and they're certainly
you know they're not going to they're
not going to continue um following the
orders of some of those people now
because now they can see but um these
are the people we need to trust going
forward because um
because well you know they really know
what's good for you and they care about
you I think there are a lot of people
now and I and I and I feel it too who
are just getting who are losing hope
again who who are who are losing hope in
the face of the just endless onslaught
of finality of and of lies of you know
lies cloaked as this is the God's honest
truth like if you can say that like that
if you can just lie about the fact that
you are lying and then everything else
that comes out of your mouth is a string
of misdirection and actual
lies what do we do like how how do how
do we find how do we find our way and I
know you have something to say to that
but let me just one last thing from this
article at the very end the claim
that the claim of what the existential
crises confronting American society are
is and so this this comes in the for of
hence in the 2024 general election we
won't confront the actual existential
crisis that we need to be confronting
which are racism chronic diseases
militarization War and the threat
thereof now I am not going to make the
claim that racism chronic diseases
militarization War and the threat
thereof aren't real threats but the idea
that those are the existential threats
to the Republic at this point to the
American people when what you see is
people losing hope because their
government has been captured and is
incapable of doing right by them the
actual existential threats to us are not
on this list they're not here well
um I would like to respond to all of
that yeah uh the existential threat is
capture right period the end and the
reason that capture is an existential
threat is because what we have in the
west is a self-correcting system
and that means that it doesn't almost
matter where we are if the system is
intact and it allowed to self-correct we
can avoid all of the other threats you
can't reduce the risk to zero but we can
reduce it as much as possible by you
know using the tools we have to engage
in good governance and the problem is
when somebody has an interest in you not
doing that and they capture the
mechanisms that would allow you to do it
you are steering towards a goal you
don't even know and
so it is capture it is the DNC is not
the only uh agent of capture but
nonetheless it is the threat to our
well-being and it is an existential
threat um but I wanted to return to your
point about it's not actionable once you
realize that the the Democratic party
has been
captured uh it it doesn't feel
actionable to people right which I think
is a dead wrong and B it it does tie in
with your point about hope now I have
said in other contexts that there is a
social problem when trying to engage
people who are interested in the
problems that you face and the issue is
this let's say we just gather a group of
people who are interested in threats to
the environment and listen you
conservatives I did not say climate
change there are threats to the
environment there are very serious ones
you might gather people
together you might talk to them about
those threats but you have a problem
because in having gathered people
together around a topic of interest you
will have gathered a room full of
people many of whom are motivated by
fear fear that terrible things are
happening and that we must confront them
the other part of that room is motivated
by hope the idea that there's something
clear to do let's get going let's do the
thing that makes things better and the
problem is neither of these groups is
wrong they're just structured
motivationally differently but if you
try to talk to that room you try to talk
to the people who are motivated by fear
you will disempower those who are
motivated by hope and if you talk to
those who are motivated by hope you will
demotivate those who are motivated by
fear and if you try to talk to them as
if they are one thing you will muddle
the message so it doesn't mean anything
and that's a problem we just all have to
recognize that these
are these are cognitive structures that
we have to front in figuring out how to
move forward
now if we level up from there the
important thing to recognize is the
Peril of this
moment could hardly be greater really
everything is on the table including a
potentially uh a nuclear exchange that
we might Bumble our way into as a result
of corruption that has us fueling a
nebulous conflict in
Ukraine so the Peril here couldn't be
greater but the opportunity is similarly
great and
this is effectively inherent to what we
call uh the Adaptive landscape metaphor
in order to go from a low Peak a peak in
which you've only attained a certain
fraction of what's possible to a higher
Peak you have to go through an Adaptive
Valley and what that means is that there
is it is inherent that you will pass
through a perilous uh frightening time
in order to get to a better time there's
no guarantee however that if you
confront it you do get to the other side
so we have to now say well what is
available to us what is in front of us
that actually results in the terrifying
realities of the moment being
substantially better two years from now
right and there are things on the table
that do that but we have to be very
careful apologies um not to allow those
things to be squandered or derailed and
we must also know that because the core
issue here is not confusion but
capture that it is certain it is 100%
certain that those things that have the
potential to make things better two
years from now are going to be targeted
intensely the intent is going to make be
to make them stumble or to eliminate
them from the map in one way or another
to make them Untouchable whatever has to
be done in order to make sure that the
things that could lead us to a better
outcome do not manage to do that that is
going to occur and we have to be ready
for it in real
time so I think one of the ways um that
people can talk past one another and
that I think um to some degree we are
talking past one another right now
because you said you think that my claim
that people are feeling
um hopeless and that there's nothing
that that that that the hopelessness
doesn't feel actionable that the what
they're experiencing doesn't feel
actionable you said that that's dead
wrong
wrong um and I mean I don't I think it
can't be dead wrong I know that people
are experiencing this so you know my
claim isn't it's not actionable my claim
is people are feeling that it's not
actionable I agree with that but
um put aside that for the
moment when I
hear when I hear you talk the way you
just we're
talking I hear Reason for Hope but I
still see I still hear very little ways
very very few roots for individuals to
do anything and I think we had we had
friends visiting um a couple weeks ago
and uh with their new baby and one of
the things you know straight couple um
one of the things uh that she said to me
and his Hants I'm not going to use their
names here um was you it was just three
of us and the baby were taking a walk in
one of the beautiful places is here in
the islands um the baby wasn't walking
um and she says to me you know often
when he and I
disagree um it turns out that we're just
talking past one another and that I have
been thinking about individual level
actions and he's been thinking about
population level
actions and I think that there is uh a a
gendered component to that I think that
um that on average uh women are more
likely to think to the like what what
can I do what is best for you know my
children what is best for my family uh
and uh men on average are more likely to
be thinking at at the sort of larger
societal level and this is consistent
with research that um is is quite good
that I wouldn't be able to pull up right
at the moment um that has been done on
in general um sort of when you're
talking about you know the forest and
the trees just versus detail um that
across a lot of domains uh and this is
uh neuro research um women are on
average um better at details and men are
on average better at gist and this is
you know again a statistical argument
and um says nothing about what you
yourself might be awesome at um but
consider when you are having
disagreements and this you know this is
very insightful on the part
of uh this this new mother um with this
you know beautiful you know new family
um thinking about the ways that um that
the two adults the husband and the wife
wife sometimes struggle to understand
what the hell the other one is going on
about um and I think it's it's this
different level of analysis it's a
different level of approach and so when
I hear you saying what you were just
saying I I still have the sense of like
yes but what can people do because you
know and I'm not and I think that you
are responding but you're responding at
the sort of like we can do this thing um
but individuals are still feeling like
helpless and hopeless because they don't
know what they can do um again uh I
don't I'm not disagreeing that that's
how people feel and I'm not saying that
I don't understand why that seems to be
the calculus um on the other hand the
problem is that the answer of what
people can do is a tremendous amount but
it is not of the style that they are
used to thinking of as meaningful action
right it is not if you say you know we
really just got to go get this shed
built you know what's the first thing I
get to do well I'm going to go out there
and level the site okay it's not that
kind of action okay here all of the
stuff that we have talked about about uh
the ash experiment the milgrim
experiment all of the things that we
have learned about Mass
formation um they should
feed they should feed into a model and
that model should tell you that actually
there's going to be a major shift in our
Consciousness over the next 14 months
and in fact there's going to be a battle
over it that is already taking place you
were reading from a weapon in that
battle yes we will shift our minds we
will come to believe things that we did
not believe the struggle is and we will
forget that we ever believed anything
different some of us right and in fact
one of the things that you can do is you
can look back on
uh commentary from even two years ago
right even our own commentary from two
years ago is jarring because it reveals
what we did understand and what we
didn't understand so just realizing how
quickly the mindset of the entire West
is changing is um both frightening and
an indicator of how much power there is
in doing a few simple things you and I
have talked about modeling your doubts
confessing them yes to people who whose
position you don't know yeah why does
that matter well it matters a because
you'll learn a ton about what people
actually think that you will not learn
from censusing what they publicly say
but two it matters
because in modeling the willingness to
say I am not on board with this
conclusion you enable others who are
somewhere in that neighborhood debating
where they fall out what they believe
and what they are willing to say you are
modeling that that is survivable and
hopefully you're modeling that it's
attractive right I like the person who
says you know what I heard them say that
and then I thought that can't be true
cause survivable attractive and they're
not the only one who has doubts that
that I think is a critical piece as well
and that
doesn't I don't think that piece of it
that piece of people's psychology looms
at all for you and I don't think it
looms nearly as large for me as it does
for most people um but that for for many
people we know that that
um we know that most people are not
willing to be the first to disagree with
what appears to be unanimity with what
appears to be consensus and these are of
course the I we don't we didn't hear
unanimous so much but we heard over and
over and over again the drum beat during
Co was consensus consensus science
follow the science this is what you do
because this is what we know we know
this is it it's
Universal and with that drum beat for
you especially if you understand that
you're not expert particularly in
whatever it is that you're being told
you think oh boy I don't know you keep
that to yourself almost everyone keeps
that to themselves now I do think and
this is a Reason for Hope is that
uh the internet you know as much as
there has been an assault on on us and
and and others uh in terms of trying to
silence us and demonetize and shadowban
and all of the things that have been
done boy are there a lot of people out
here there are a lot of people who are
saying yep that did happen to me and
still I didn't except the shot I didn't
go along with it I didn't put up a don't
hurt me wall on my business I didn't do
the thing and hey I survived I went
through the Looking Glass I'm on the
other side and I'm still standing and
once more I have my health and my
Integrity intact like that's the thing
right and it has material implications
the willingness you know when the
vaccine campaign started the um idea of
opposing something called a vaccine was
so an Asma to such a large percentage of
the
population that it seemed impossible but
saying actually let us look at the
science here right does the science
match what we are being told oh no it's
not a match at all doesn't tell you
what's true but it does tell you I have
a I have a license to slow down and
think very very carefully about what's
being said because I know that at face
value it's just wrong and then the story
comes yes yes yes we actually we didn't
tell you exactly the whole truth because
really the people are stupid I mean
that's the message right the people are
stupid they can't handle the truth they
wouldn't understand the truth so we had
to put this gloss on it we like well you
you know what your gloss your gloss went
180 degrees what the data actually said
to the degree that you were even willing
to share your data with us right so your
gloss isn't a gloss at the point that
it's a lie a Flatout opposite lie not
only is it a lie it is a lie that
actually has a physical manifestation a
hypodermic NE that carries a toxic
mixture of substances that we now I mean
it's incredible what turns out to have
been in these things never mind what was
in them that we knew about that was
horrifying enough but what actually
turned out to be in them was a disaster
yeah so the point is people who woke up
early the earlier you woke up the less
times that hypodermic needle penetrated
your skin and injected that stuff into
you people are now understandably
feeling frightened for how many doses
they took and relieved at how many they
didn't take so the point is it's not an
abstraction right right these are
concrete things that have implications
for your health among other things
so when we are looking at a 14-month
time Horizon in which until the general
election until the general election in
which uh look I don't know maybe the
degree of control has moved gone in the
last four years far more than I
know or the last seven years but uh I
believe there's still a horse race here
and I believe that they will do
everything in their power to prevent
that horse race from happening and what
can you do amounts to think about the
emergent fact of our Collective
understanding of what is taking place we
have proven that over the course of
months to years we can actually break a
narrative designed to harm us and we can
wake people up in large enough numbers
that we can derail that thing okay now
the question is this is going to be
different but it's going to be the same
style of interaction you want to be
early amongst the people who understand
what's actually taking place that
understands which reflexes of yours are
being used to steer you into self harm
so that you can stop them right a reflex
is not fate it's a predisposition and to
to recognize what is going to be stolen
from us here and how to prevent it you
can play a very important role the same
role that you have played in Breaking
the narrative that was fed to us over
public health and coid and that is not
small it is abstract that's the problem
the problem is it is not level the sight
to build the the shed it is well but but
you but you gave an actionable answer
which is one that we've given before
which is share your doubts in whatever
form it seems possible however vaguely
however specifically it seems possible
with those you meet at the you know at
the coffee drive-thru when you're
picking up your dry cleaning uh with uh
you know do people have paper boys
anymore I don't know but you know with
with people maybe just strangers at
first with whom you don't think that you
will have iterated interactions but then
start with the people who with whom you
might have iterated interactions and and
and go from there I we don't have these
experiences as much not living in a city
anymore but um it was always remarkable
how many people sort of lit up and
became relieved at the point that it was
Poss it became clear that they were
allowed that they were being allowed by
the person on the other side of the
interaction to share their doubts and
once people start to realize that many
many many people among us share doubts
about the directions that things are
going and the authorities proclaiming
that things are under control and uh you
don't need to worry your pretty little
heads about it um the the more hope we
will have and it will be
justified yeah
actually I think I think this is right
and I would say to make it even more
actionable much of what matters takes
place online so I'm not saying don't do
this stuff online but it is vitally
important tough online because there's
so much garbage now there's so many
things that you can interact with that
clear patently aren't human right I'm
not all I'm saying is if we abandon
online because it's uh a very dangerous
landscape we lose so we can't do that
right but it does not mean that the key
thing for you to do is not to establish
trust offline with it's not going to be
a ton of people but enough people that
as things go increasingly crazy you can
look somebody in the eye and say is this
making sense to you here's why I don't
think it's true right if you can do that
with people offline you
are I won't say immune but um
resistant to being steered no I think I
think that's right I actually had this
experience a bit this week it wasn't
online it was you know with with a new
acquaintance friend um who I met in the
street and and she said you know I got
this I have this newsletter from this
epidemiologist that I really like and
what she just sent I'm just I I think it
makes sense but can you can you look at
it uh and I did and it made no sense to
me and um you know I clicked through on
a bunch of the links in the newsletter
and none of them went to the sources
that she claimed they went to they went
to CDC recommendations instead of actual
science and uh you know it was just it
was just another one of these things
saying no matter what if you're feeling
sick you need to get your booster that
that was the message and um at first I
thought oh I like I don't know I'm a
little surprised that
this that this felt like something that
I might respond to positively at all but
that doesn't that doesn't matter let me
figure out exactly why this this feels
wrong to me and give as um as precise a
response as I can and I did and the
response came back thank you so much I'm
it's so hard to know what to think for
people who aren't and I don't remember
exactly what the examples were
epidemiologists vaccinologists
virologists Public Health people and I
thought boy but this is such a smart
accomplished person and um you all of us
all of us need to be assessing as
opposed to taking from on high someone
with the you know the public health
degree ah I'm saying that you should do
this okay but why are you saying it you
speak like this it's written in the
language of in the style it's written in
the the style of science so not only do
they have the degrees and the right
words and the platforms that we are
accustomed to thinking of as bringing us
the the the unvarnished truth about
public health um but
increasingly it's hiding really
successfully behind all of the usual
things that scientists do and almost all
of them turn out to be Pumkin papers
like and sometimes you can't tell like
most people aren't posting their data
for you for us to directly look at but I
mean just just the citations every every
single time now and there's a bunch more
of these that I was running into today
it's like oh that doesn't I don't think
that claim is right and you go and look
at the citation that they that they give
to back up the claim and it's just not
there there's no there there
so it's no one else checking well like I
at some ofel I'm just I'm just shocked
at the level to which for instance the
safe and effective claim is just being
regurgitated and regurgitated and
regurgitated and there's no new research
that's saying it is presumably there's
no research saying it is because there
can't be and so these people are relying
on claims from a kid you not um we're
going to get there maybe later today um
from like February 2021 ah they're safe
and effective are you kidding most
people hadn't even been vaccinated at
that point how would you know so uh
there is a very clear Point logically
speaking about how to address this and
I'm concerned about making this point
because I know exactly how it will be
misused okay um so I want to Forstall
the misuse before I tell you what the
point is the misuse is going to involve
the battle um over the analysis of the
quality of
evidence in different studies right okay
so uh in a meta analysis looking at a a
study and saying this is lowquality
evidence versus this is high quality
evidence does not mean what those words
sound like they
imply um these things have been studied
and in the case of wellone studies that
is studies that were properly conducted
low quality studies and high quality
studies reach the same conclusion it
does not change what they discover right
it may leave larger error bars but it
does not change the
conclusion so that is the place where we
have to be very careful not to apply
what I'm about to
say
public is convinced in a bizarre way
that
quantity um is a strong indicator of
accuracy in other words the number of
places that you read a particular
conclusion is an indicator that that
conclusion is likely to be right yep and
this is nonsense for a couple reasons um
most importantly if you
have a wrong
conclusion that because your corporation
sells of something or other you need
that wrong conclusion to be widely
distributed amongst doctors let's
say you can
produce evidence that will capture
attention and spread and appear to be
many people reaching a conclusion when
in fact they've done no analysis
whatsoever a single study that is
independent of that corrupting apparatus
will likely reach the right conclusion
and so you may have a c of people saying
X and the truth may be why and the truth
may exist only in that paper but what
you absolutely need to do is figure out
whether or not that sea of things is a
bunch of people repeating conclusions
that they've heard and have not
established for themselves um whether
there is a perverse incentive Etc
and so here's here's the punchline of
the of the analysis
it is better to process less of what you
encounter when you have no idea which
stuff is polluted by perverse incentives
processing very little data is not a
fatal problem in fact it may be the only
way to see clearly if what you process
is all valid it was all properly done
but you fail to process most stuff that
you can't assess whether it was properly
done you will reach a robust conclusion
it won't have what amounts to the
statistic IAL power of that huge sea of
wrong things but that statistical power
is misleading it's pulling you in the
wrong direction right the trick of
course is figuring out what to read and
what not to right of course of course
which then the problem is that is
unsayable right what people think
including most people with Advanced
degrees what they think is that the job
of a scientist is to look at the data
what does that mean look at the papers
on that topic and process it and figure
out well what explains it no no I'm
sorry that does not work where you have
corruption the the job is not to take
the sum total of everything that has
been published in a peer-reviewed
journal on a topic and make it all make
sense because corruption derails that
and honestly I mean it's it's a strange
conclusion that we've that we you know
science the science Community has come
to that is wrong because you know what
is historically I don't know how far
back this goes but um I think if you
were to ask a scientist publishing in
the
1950s what is the purpose of literature
review uh it is to give you a sense of
what is currently believed on the topic
and what has been done and then when you
come to write your paper if this is a
topic on which you are doing original
research the literature review uh
appears is reflected in that paper in
two places um primarily it's in the
introduction by way of setting up what
the issue is what we think we know what
has been done already and what the
opportunity is for new research and then
the literature view can also come up in
the discussion but largely it comes up
in the discussion by way of this new
research either is coincident with or
goes to falsify the U previous
understanding about this
topic the literature review is not the
conclusion and so you know review papers
are trying to do to do that to say okay
what is it that we what is the state of
the art as it were what is the state of
the science uh but the whole point is
what are you doing what are you adding
and maybe what you're adding is actually
a falsification of everything that came
before you know that's not the common
thing that's not the most that's not the
most regular thing but it certainly
happens and it may actually you know
provide uh a Nuance that then allows
other people to go well wait maybe the
truth is actually over there and this is
kind of close enough that this looks
like the truth but it's but it's not
there none of none of these reasons to
do a literature review which I have done
plenty of um ever suggest that what
you're doing is trying to figure out
from that literature review based on
consensus based on averages what is true
the idea of statistically speaking most
of the papers say this therefore the
truth must lie somewhere
therein no yeah the problem
is the rules the formal rules of
Academia make it impossible to behave uh
as one logically should in an
environment as polluted as this one yeah
so let's suppose that you have an author
and you've done deep Dives on a couple
of their pieces of work and you've
discovered what amounts to fraud cor
right okay papers haven't been
retracted now my thought let's take bull
Weare for example Who Bull Weare who is
one of the uh primary uh corruptors of
the science around I
them okay um if I see a paper on some
topic with bulwar as an author I'm not
processing
it can I say that no wait this person is
you're not processing material produced
by this person are you saying they're
incapable of doing a proper study no I'm
not saying anything of the kind what I'm
saying is I've twice seen evidence of
this person doing something that
constitutes an inversion of correct
science so
I'm not processing their work because I
don't know anything about whether
there's any information in it or how I
would figure that out yeah right what is
the scientific language for I um here is
a literature review on this topic
excluding work uh that involved
bullar there's no way to say that
academically so the point is it's game
over in fact the this is used um Often
by
those by those who would have you ignore
Innovative work and I'm I'm I'm losing
the names I've lost the names of the
people but there are you know a few
doctors uh early in the AIDS crisis uh
who were saying you know actually I
think um I think this virus is involved
but it may not be the only thing causal
and I think we need to be thinking about
you know these these other possible
causal factors and uh it became they
became such parias that all you had to
do was mention their names and it's like
okay you don't need to pay any attention
to that research so this is OB like as
with all
tools they can be used in order to help
you um do better in the world understand
the world better and make it a better
place and the inverse as well
yeah the problem is power is power and
rules are gameable and scientific rules
are especially gameable because
effectively science has done on the
honor System and um anyway we're kind of
far a field from from where we started
but the um ability to process
selectively you have to do it in a way
that is unbiased if you're going to
process only things that match your
pre-existing belief then you're just
going to reinforce it that's
scientifically invalid but if you're
going to be very cautious and not
process information that um uh you have
no reason to suspect is accurate in a
place where there's a lot of inaccurate
information then actually you protect if
you limit yourself to processing only
those things which have you have reason
to believe are reliable you will get a
lower power higher quality conclusion
from it and it is really the only way to
keep one's Clarity I no it's that is an
approach that you take that other people
I know take I is not what I do um but
then I have an easier time processing
high amounts of visual text so I mean I
I think I think there are going to be
different approaches valid for different
um kinds of processing Styles and and
techniques and um you know knowing what
is out there uh also has value um
well I think we are now talking past
each other if you've got Pharma spending
who knows how many million dollar to
pollute a small quadrant I to spend a
lot of time with the Pharma funded
studies that's what I'm saying though is
if you are trying to deal with a
conclusion that involves topics on which
Pharma has taken an interest yeah how do
you deal with with the vast quantity of
wrong uh information that has pumped
into the literature this is what the uh
conflicts of interest statements are
supposed to be about in the papers and
we know we know very often that authors
either don't even declare them or
pretend that the very real conflicts
that they have be because they've been
getting funding from exactly the
organizations that Ser stand to profit
uh if they come up with one answer not
another um just aren't conflicts at all
so um you know it's at every level you
have it's very very difficult to know
what you're looking at so the honor
System in a system with no honor um
let's just I think we're going to save a
bunch of what we're going to do today um
for for next time but I did want to talk
a tiny bit about the Atlantic this month
and then you want to talk about the New
York Times
right so um we talked about Harpers the
October 2023 cover craving a choice
Insurgency and its threat to the
Democratic party uh the Atlantic you can
show my screen briefly here Zach um has
in its October 2023 uh uh
issue um a book review by Helen Lewis
from feminist to right-wing conspiracist
what Naomi Wolf's Odyssey can teach us
about seeing patterns where they don't
exist yeah so uh I'm going to again just
read uh a little bit from this truly
remarkable article which is again it's a
book review
of um Naomi kleene who was Klein's new
book called doppelganger in which she
apparently is
um I have not read the book I've read
the book review um basically talking
about how strange and it seems like how
awful it is that people can't seem to
tell her apart from Naomi wolf who we
can all understand as readers of Harpers
must be a right-wing conspiracist Nut
Job the Atlantic I keep on getting it
wrong um must be a right-wing conspiracy
nut job right well no um but here we
go if the intelligencia wouldn't lionize
wolf than the banite right would she
would she could enter a world where
mistakes don't matter no one feels shame
and fact Checkers are derided as finger
wagging
elitists these people don't disappear
just because we can no longer see them
Klein reminds any fellow leftists who
might be enthusiastic about public
humiliation as a weapon against the
right denied access to the mainstream
media the ostracized will be welcomed on
one America news network and Newsmax on
or social media sites such as Rumble
getter gab truth social and Elon musk's
new all crazy all thee time
Reincarnation of Twitter as X on
podcasts the entire heterodox space
Revels in just asking questions and then
not caring about the peer- reviewed
Answers by escaping to what CLE calls
the mirror World wolf might have lost
cultural capital but she has not lost an
audience clein notes this world is
particularly hospitable to those who can
blend personal and social grievances
into an appealing populist message I am
despised by the pointy heads just as you
are she Ventures a kind of equation for
leftists and liberals crossing over to
the authoritarian right that goes
something like this narcissism
grandiosity plus social media addiction
plus midlife crisis plus public shaming
equals right-wing
meltdown she's inclined to
downplay quote that bit of math though
and feels uncomfortable putting wolf on
the couch nonetheless I this is Helen
Lewis talking now am struck by how
narcissism in the ubiquitous lay sense
of the term is key to understanding
conspiracy theorist influences and their
followers if you feel disrespected and
overlooked in everyday life then being
flattered with the idea that you're a
special person with secret knowledge
must be
appealing this is
amazing um you wanted to interject or
you want me to read
the so a couple more uh bits from this
article uh which
is decrying the so-called Descent of
Naomi wolf into right-wing conspiracy
land which
no a book by Naomi Klein called
doppelganger a trip into the mirror
world to explore this ambitious agenda
the book ranges widely and sometimes
tangentially at one point Klein finds
herself listening to hours of War Room
hosted by a man who has built a dark
Empire of profitable Hal truths why does
kleene find Bannon so compelling here
doppelganger takes a startling turn the
answer is that quite simply game
recognizes this game Klein's cohort on
the left attacks big farmer profits
worries about surveillance capitalism
and sees Davos in the G7 as a cozy cabal
exploiting the poor it's the shades of
that uh Harper's article right like just
a brief moment of Illumination of self-
recognition well no no it's not even
that what it is is a description of
reality set up to be portrayed as an
illusion understandably she hears other
Naomi other she hears other
Naomi talk with Bannon about vaccine
manufacturers profits rail against big
Tech's power to control us and make the
case that CLA Schwab with the world
economic Forum has Untold secret power
and she can't help noting some
underlying
similarities when banon criticizes MSNBC
and CNN for running shows sponsored by
fizer telling his audience that this is
evidence of rule by the wealthy for the
wealthy against you Klein writes it
strikes me that he sounds like Nome
Chomsky or Chris Smalls the Amazon labor
union leader known for his e the rich
Jack
or for that matter
me one last thing from this
article Klein successfully makes the
case that the American left is more
Tethered to reality than the right not
because it is composed of smarter or
better people but because it has not
lost touch with the mechanisms such as
scientific peer review and media
pluralism that act as a check on our
worst
instance so this is as the Harper's
article a just a mashup
of I think glimmers of insight where
even the people most certain that the
thing hasn't changed and that they are
still on the right side of history and
that they always have and they always
will be no matter what they are being
told about how much they have to betray
what their values were just
yesterday but it can't see it it's just
like it's coming up against them hard
surface over and over and over again it
can't see it and Naomi wolf who we'll
talk again a little bit about I guess
next time um has made errors as we all
have um but she is not what is being
portrayed here and she is repeatedly
standing up for the values that she has
been standing up for her entire career
um I I want people to focus on what
you're calling glimmers of insight
because I really don't think that they
are what you're seeing them as okay
first of all I don't know what Helen
Lewis is but this is not our first
encounter with her people who watch
Darkhorse will remember that she came
after me on a an interview with Barry
Weiss and she I wish we had it but she
effectively launched into some analysis
in which he said well you can say to
Brett Weinstein and then she got Meely
mouthed and said a bunch of words that
didn't quite fit together as if what she
had just done was laid out a very clear
case against I think it was the
effectiveness of ion and then the next
sentence was like but he simply does not
get it right now there was no content in
it but the point was this was girl talk
this was two sophisticated women of the
world having a discussion in which they
say look you can say truth to Brett
Weinstein and he just simply cannot
recognize it so my point is this is a
tactical person this is a person who is
attempting to elevate certain people's
uh Stars I wasn't suggesting that Helen
Lewis was having glimmer of insight here
I was suggesting that Naomi kleene was
having a glimmer of insight that was a
quote from Naomi kleene or or a a maybe
not a quote but a a paraphrase of what
is in Klein's book in which Klein is
saying huh actually this reminds me very
much of wellknown Chomsky and and me
frankly so I I you know I I want I I
want to S have hope for some of the
people who have been standing up
historically for the same things that
now the People Like Us who are being
reviled as right-wing conspiracy
theorists are standing up for so look I
I agree and I hold out that hope but not
much I I will you probably remember that
um Naomi kleene spoke at Evergreen days
before it melted down I do um and I went
to it I do
um such a weird world yeah it's such a
weird world but you know as far as I
know she did not at any point uh discuss
the horrors of what had taken apart this
campus that she uh had just been at had
just been at and had uh apparently
affinity for she should have been
horrified and she was not at least
publicly horrified yeah um so I'm I'm
concerned the Optics weren't good I I I
want to
appreciate uh Naomi Klein but I'm on
alert and my sense is that she is
captured by something and this something
is powerful and what I believe that she
is doing and Helen Lewis is quoting is
it is tactical and the tactic is look
there's part of every liberal every
Democrat that's saying wait are we sure
Farm is on our team because I keep being
told to embrace what farma is up to wait
how long has that been going on for are
we sure that we support this war because
that doesn't remind me of us right
they're doing this all the time they
have they have to be right right so the
point is that's normal normal is like
hey wait a minute 5 minutes ago we were
we were the party that didn't like
racism and now we're being told it's the
only solution to the problems we've got
are we sure we checked that right so
that's every every Democrat that's still
got their mind is going through that so
what do you need yeah well that is a
very beautiful magazine right it has
long been a lovely magazine the kind of
magazine that when it arrived at your
house you thought that's great I wonder
what lovely things are going to be in
there for the next two weeks I might be
flipping through that thing and I might
find wonderful things that you and I
will quote to each other over breakfast
who knows right that's what it
was before the rabies the rabies the
rabies right um breakfast before rabies
breakfast before yeah exactly but here's
the
point
okay what are you going to do you've got
literally a 100 million people wondering
what the is going on that they're
suddenly embracing all of the stuff that
they used to dislike how do you shut
that up that doesn't sound entirely
wrong yeah probably about the right
order of magnitude anyway yeah what do
you do oh well you use the um the thing
that used to be the
Atlantic to broadcastcast an internal
conversation yeah where it's like isn't
it crazy that I used to be anti-war I
used to think Pharma was the problem
right but now the sophisticated blah
blah blah is we're waste moved on from
that Helen Lewis Naomi Klein blah blah
blah so the point is this is a mechanism
for getting a tension that naturally
cannot help but arise in the mind of a
voter to resolve in a particular
direction by basically stepping them
through the process of forgetting well
and I think actually the again um I
think one piece of this that you're
missing is the see other smart people
think like you do other smart people are
also questioning this but they're still
on the side of right they've they've
they've been staunch they aren't they
aren't leaving the party they are not
changing they're still doing what the
party tells them to do they are still
proar and pro- Pharma and pro corporate
profits and you know anti- the little
people because that's what we Democrats
stand for it's like wait wait wait what
did you say no no no they're still on
the right side of History just remember
that and carry on wait in fact it um
this is now coming together I think
there is a process right an emergent
process exactly the one we were talking
about in our discussion of where hope
comes from that if you actually model
your doubts for somebody that you can
create trust and a willingness for them
to confess their doubts you can free
yourself from whatever this control
apparatus is well the antidote to that
is to turn that conversation instead of
something that you actually produce and
participate in into a consumer good
we're going to have that conversation in
front of you it's here in the Atlantic
right you're having a debate in your
mind there's a part of you that's like
wait I can't believe we're now the the
the people who like Pharma right and
we're going to show you how somebody who
you respect somebody you know lovely
who's been there all along right how she
resolves that so you don't have to worry
about it honey
right and it is it is that and I I
believe this you know at the end of the
day I don't think we're ever going to
get a complete analysis of how this
happened but I do think this is fifth
generation Warfare where the
problem is that all of the people who
don't understand that they have been
targeted they have not been specifically
targeted but what has happened is they
have been successfully modeled and
people who have become expert in nudging
yes right are doing it and they are
doing it through everything that you
would look to to figure out how to think
more clearly they're going to nudge the
population off the cliff like so many
bison right but of course you know the
Atlantic you know look the Atlantic
speaks to the exact tension that they
pretend to resolve in that set of
paragraphs right well no mean I don't
think they pretend to resolve it but I
think what they do is they leave the
reader with a sense of well okay the
best Among Us Naomi Klein has recognized
that there's a slight conundrum but
she's still decided this therefore I can
put my fears to rest it's the smarter
people than me yeah which is one of
those phrases that I know you and I both
detest right it is one of these phrases
that does a ton of heavy lifting and
it's nonsense yeah um the idea that
smarter people than you boy you ought to
go hang out with some of those smarter
people cuz some of them are are dumb as
can be yeah um so yes I I it I do think
it's fifth generation Warfare I do think
the Atlantic can I ask a what are the do
you know what the first four
generation I just I just I've not heard
sticks and ston I I don't know I'm I'm
I'm borrowing a phrase and I should be
more expert in knowing exactly what
those Generations are but um but anyway
I do believe that this is a highly
sophisticated psychological nudge tactic
in which you don't realize that be just
because they aren't thinking of you by
name doesn't mean that you don't exist
in their model and they haven't figured
out what sources you pay attention to
and how you read them and what you think
about them and how they're going to use
them to get you to arrive at the a
pseudo smart conclusion that will cause
you to do self harm
yep okay so we've got um Harpers going
after Maran Williamson RFK Jr and
Cornell West the Atlantic going after
Naomi wolf and uh the new y times went
after you yeah it sure did yeah um yeah
it did in the form of a piece by Yasha
monk now Yasha monk is somebody that I
I've never met him in person as far as I
know um but I do know him a little bit
um I was involved in a uh a back Channel
conversation with a lot of interesting
people um and so I would have said he
and I were friendly and so anyway he's
uh if you want why don't
you
how to argue against identity politics
without turning into a react scenar
would you like to read the first few
paragraphs I really really would
um in the spring of 2017 a senior
administrator at Evergreen State College
in Washington announced that she
expected excuse
me that she expected white students and
faculty members to stay off campus for a
day the so-called day of absent she
explained was intended to build
community around identity one Professor
publicly pushed back against this idea
as he wrote to the administrator on a
college campus one's right to speak or
to be must never be based on skin color
he would he announced remain on campus
What followed was a bizarre Gauntlet
though the day of absence was officially
voluntary the professor's refusal to
take part painted a Target on his back
protesters disrupted one of his classes
intimidating his students and accusing
him of being a racist the campus police
he said encouraged him to keep away from
his for his own safety within a few
months he quit his job Reinventing
himself as a public intellectual for the
internet age in his early media
appearances the professor Brett
Weinstein described himself as a leftist
but over time he drifted away from his
political Roots embracing ever more
outlandish conspiracy theories of late
he has insinuated that the September 11
attacks were inside job and called for
health officials who recommended that
children be vaccinated against coid to
face prosecution modeled on the narber
trials okay so one more sentence Mr
Weinstein and short has fallen into the
reactionary trap oh that doesn't sound
good no yeah so
um first of all
let me just say um that uh Yasha monk is
a lot of things apparently uh he's
involved in the council in foreign
relations he is a regular uh at the
Atlantic um he's associated with uh
Johns Hopkins which I will get to in a
second but the thing you're pull there
or not yeah okay let's show uh Mike Ben
uh tweet in which Mike Ben notices that
Yasha monk has gone after
me um he says classic example here of
everything I talk about a hitpiece on
Brett Weinstein for conspiracies in
quotes Etc essentially arguing to censor
him um who's it by not some pink-haired
I can't remember ambig gendered ibram X
Kendy Council on Foreign Relations
John's Hopkins Atlantic foreign policy
blah BL
okay so um Yasha is doing a job here
I find this despicable and I will tell
you that I find Yasha despicable and the
reason for that is what happened when I
contacted him and asked him to correct
the error in those paragraphs that he
that you just
read um he expressed relief that I was
being civil he fully expected me to be
very angry at him for what he did and I
asked him to correct this thing and he
came back and he said I'm not going to
correct it because I believe it is
accurate um and I said it is not
accurate and I explained to him why are
you going to explain to us why I will
okay um and he ghosted me so what I find
duplicitous here is that what he is
effectively saying is this was not
personal um in fact he expressed an
interest that although we differ on a
lot of things in the future we might
find alignment right after he has
described me as effectively the type
specimen of something he calls the
reactionary trap he falsely portrays me
as no longer being um a liberal as I
claim never explains why that is blames
it on conspiracy theories and then he
comes up with two examples now the two
examples he says that I claim that 9911
was an inside job yep which I did not
insinuated that the September 11 attacks
were an inside job right and the second
thing is he says that I believe that
there should be some sort of nurmberg
trial for people who uh sought to
inoculate children healthy children um
with uh the co vaccines now on the
second count I'm definitely there I
believe that these things cannot be
justified for kids and that people who
are in a position to know how dangerous
that is and are still recommending them
are actually involved in a a crime
against humanity so we don't disagree on
that I certainly disagree that that
makes me anything other than a
liberal um but in the case of the 9/11
attacks he reveals something that I
think is extremely important you want me
to show his and the link the link that
he gives is this tweet of yours the
evidence for your
insinuation so if click through on his
link I've got it Zack so why you put it
up uh this is you from September 11th
2023 them the conspir you want to read
it or you want me to read it okay this
is them speaking the conspiracy
theorists are wrong about 9911 this is
me speaking whoo so then what do you
believe them the 9/11 commission me how
is that not a conspiracy theory them
yeah okay but you know what I mean me
actually I D I doubt either of us do now
my point there is that the idea that
conspiracy theory is a useful way to
dismiss some explanation of 9/11 is
preposterous since all of the
explanations from 911 are conspiracy
theories that does not say one way or
the other what I think happened MH so he
then digs deeper um do you want to show
his other tweet the breakdown of what
you said uh the the one that cites the
podcast with Jeremy riss and
uh you got to make it bigger Michael
Shermer yeah Michael Shermer and Jeremy
riss okay Yasha monk read
this um you do it yeah go ahead so this
is Yasha monk responding to me saying
that I did not insinuate that 911 was an
inside jop all right Yasha says is this
you Brett video highlights video below
highlights from transcript included here
Brett Weinstein quote I see patterns of
anomalies that refuse to dissipate on
inspection Michael Shermer to me that
the theory that this was an inside job
by the Bush Administration is a
distraction from the real issue
Weinstein but some of the an anomal
aren't little things to got on Earth
because people are looking at every
detail shmer like what Weinstein well
it's a cliche at this point but the way
building Seven Falls doesn't make any
sense to me Shermer yeah it does I think
so and you know who also knows the
insurance companies that had to pay the
claims off they investigated
this uh end of that string other things
Weinstein says later in this
conversation those cell phone calls have
never made much sense to me the making
of phone calls in 2001 from a plane uh
calls that did not frustratingly drop
almost instantly does not add up if and
then Yasha again if all of this isn't
insinuating that people who believe 911
was an inside job may be right I don't
know what would be okay so Yasha is
involved in a trick and I'm going to
point out just how dangerous that trick
is and I don't know that Yasha knows
that he's doing this I think he's just
carrying water and I will explain the
purpose of it in a second but
the point is if you
express surprise doubt
concern over any detail of a story then
you are on the other team there are two
teams one team is called team inside job
and the other team is called not a
conspiracy theory okay now not there are
two teams only two teams that shall ever
only be two teams and so and join a team
Brett you you've not join a team not
join a team at all his point is you've
indicated that you're not on our team
therefore you're on the other team
you're on the other team I have a right
to drag you over the claim that this is
an inside job because you expressed
doubt about the official version now
this does not add up and in fact if
you'll put that Tweet back up and show
the Tweet um that you responded to him
that he was responding to me over with
that uh one
second
okay I
say no Yasha you are logically
incompetent if I say I don't believe the
Magic Bullet there must have been a
second gunman have I insinuated that the
CIA killed Kennedy obviously not to say
the 9/11 commission Advanced conspiracy
Advanced a conspiracy theory is a simple
statement of fact okay so he is
frustrated he feels entitled to do this
to me because I have expressed doubt
about details of the 9911 commission's
um uh explanation now will you put up
that uh Isaac azimov quote that I sent
you uh
yes electricity electric a very
important give me one no no don't worry
about it this is a very important quote
it comes from Isaac asof and uh it is
one that is near and dear to me I've
quoted it many times the most exciting
phrase to hear in science the one that
Heralds new discoveries is not Eureka
but that's
funny now what aamof means here he says
it very cleverly but what he means is
that the way we make progress is we look
at things that don't add up it's always
the things that don't add up that cause
you to discover important things now I
would like you to
compare this deep Insight of Isaac
azimov with uh Yasha Monk's apparent
position his point is as soon soon as
you notice anything that doesn't add up
you're automatically on a team and we
are now entitled to hold you responsible
for the worst excesses the biggest
errors um the most embarrassing episodes
from that team yep that is obviously not
only logically incorrect but would be
devastating to our progress as a species
if we are not allowed if there are if
you're going to turn logical analysis
into teams and you are going to force
people onto the other team as soon as
they say hey I'm not fully on board with
X right you are ending scientific
progress okay so that's the analysis of
and mind you another friend of yash's
jumped into the fry actually went to the
podcast in which I talked to um Jeremy R
and and Michael
Shermer and put together a little edit
that supposedly catches me dead to wrs
and in fact they zoom in on my shaking
my head just slightly as Jeremy riss uh
reveals that uh Paul Bremer um uh that
Paul Bremer both um didn't happen to be
in the building um when it this was one
of the main Towers when it went down but
then uh went on television that evening
blamed Osama Bin Laden and then became
the uh uh the occupation governor in
Iraq an interesting set of um facts now
I don't take those those facts to be
meaningful in and of themselves so are
you saying that
um we are obligated to notice nothing
out of step with the mainstream story we
are obligated to notice nothing at all
lest we be shunted into the other team
that is the that is the new rule and I
will point out notice this this is the
same rule that applied to vaccine safety
and effect Effectiveness oh right
antivaxers the way down the point is and
notice also and this was in that piece
that you just read the idea that just
asking questions is now an embarrassment
right oh we've caught you you're using
that excuse you're just asking
questions well how exactly would you
have us arrive at any useful conclusion
without tripping over your trap over
asking questions right asking questions
is what we do even if the answer is it's
it's remarkable I remember I think it
was Sam Harris who started being like
he's just asking questions like we
actually never say that that's that's
not a phrase that we use ever right cuz
it doesn't need a defense exactly like
how in what world are the people who are
refusing to ask questions the heroes
right what world is that and how if if
if one team has it so dead to rights how
did they get there without asking
questions and so quickly right and so
cleanly and looking so smart about I
must say I loved Jimmy door's bit it's
an adjacent bit but Jimmy door
has a beautiful Riff on uh uh doing your
own research which he points out used to
be called reading um that's right so
this is the same thing what they want to
do and again fifth generation Warfare
they want to demonize the very things
that might set you free which is doing
enough of your own research that is to
say reading asking proper questions
noticing
anomalies even if the answer is that the
911 commission's report which I will
point out Max Cleland quit the 9
commission saying it was a cover up a
member of the 911 Commission quit saying
that the Bush Administration was
covering up that's you don't need any
license to question the 911 Commission
but the fact that somebody who was on it
reached that conclusion and stormed off
is license then again
so the fact is they want why don't you
just follow orders well and why don't I
abide I mean it's remarkable really like
the piece is set up the New York Times
piece the oped um like here's a guy who
demonstrated that he won't actually
follow a moral
orders and we didn't even make any
orders here it was just understood that
if you're going to be a good Democrat
you got to follow the orders which is
that we don't even have to say because
it's so understood what they are and
you're now a bad person because you did
not follow the implied stuff it was
really easy for a number of the pseudo
heterodox types to get behind you and me
and others like oh yeah that was obvious
because it was so explicitly racist what
they were doing at Evergreen but really
that that that uh interest in heterodoxy
was real sh
and the guy who is portraying me as the
example of what you should not become
right that guy is privately relieved
that uh I'm actually not that mad at him
and uh there's hope for us uh you know
Finding alignment in the future the
point is this is this is tactical again
and I want to point out what the use of
the tactic is why it's showing up here
and
now yeah are you a dangerous reactionary
or are you not I am not no I'm I'm
talking from inside the the space of
someone who would hope that he can still
be friends right to him am I a dangerous
reactionary or not is exactly the right
question and the answer is of course I'm
not right right but this I was not
actually asking you that question
forgive
me okay so why do this mhm here's the
problem the New York Times Atlantic
cabal Harpers I think Harpers is in
trouble I mean yeah yeah I certainly
look the Atlantic is at the epicenter of
some new thing right that has interests
in the world it shapes positions it
controls Minds it's the very it's the
epicenter of the location that that uh
Sam Harris is coming from
now it has a problem
mhm woke is a big loser and we're still
we're right there at that uh 14 months
13 13 months
left okay they have to distance
themselves from woke yeah with regard to
that the general election is what that
that will be deciding in the general
it's going to be devastating so there's
a big pivot on and here's the problem
and you named it at the beginning of
this it's middle ground ground scramble
stuff because what what happens what
happens if now you admit that actually
you know in spite of all the ink that
was spilled in the New York Times over
wokeness right and the glory of it you
have to admit that that was wrong oh
who do you have to go talk to now
not us yeah no this is exactly what you
would have to do so okay don't don't
panic people how are we going to deal
with this how are we not going to
empower the people who tried to warn you
not to do that woke because it was
going to devastate Western Civilization
which it is now doing how are you going
to Pivot away without empowering those
people well you have to specially
demonize them right it's called the
reactionary trap that's the reason you
don't have to talk to those people they
weren't really right right they sort of
you know it's more Sam harrism ISM right
right for the wrong reasons every clock
will be correct a couple times a day
right some bumbling Professor he kind of
happened to get it right and that was
sort of cool but then wow you know you
know how it is with those professors
from State Schools they're not really
the sharpest tools in the shed so uh you
know they fall into something the
reactionary trap yeah right where they
think it's actually some sort of
violation of the nmber code to inject
children with mRNA vaccines for a
disease that they're not susceptible to
yeah and you know what else they believe
9/11 was an inside job I can prove it
here he says the physics of building
seven falling down wasn't uh a match for
What was
seen okay thanks Yasha that's uh that's
that's good logic I think you should
really quickly clarify because it's
clear to me exactly what you're saying
but I don't think everyone will get your
difference between the terms inside job
and for example cover up or I or I don't
know what happened but okay it doesn't
seem like it Happ that's fair um my
point is there are lots of things about
the story that we were presented by the
911 Commission that do not appear to add
up I do not know what that means right I
certainly take Michael shermer's uh what
I believe is a good faith response to
this uh much more seriously than Yasha
Monk's uh cynical
one but the fact is I don't know why
building seven falls down the way it
does but I do know that if the idea is
that there was a fire that burned all
day in building s which apparently there
was and it somehow weakened the
structure enough to bring it down in
fact I said to Michael Shermer let's
just grant that there was something
stored in there that uh caused it to be
fatally compromised by fire it doesn't
fall down Straight Like That Something
gives first it leans over it twists some
part of it collapses some other part of
it remains standing now is it possible
that there is an explanation which does
simply connect office fires to that
collapse maybe I'm open to to that but
what I'm not open to is pretending that
the physics that we all learned in high
school and college is a match for fire
bringing down a building in that way I
don't know what I'm looking at what I'm
looking at is an anomaly that is worth
exploring so anyway
um I believe that's that's what I have
to say um I just want people to pay
attention to the Tactical nature of
these attacks the purpose is to make
sure that we don't empower the people
who you know do they really want to pay
the price of talking about the uh
criminality of the vaccination campaign
over mRNA because they now have to admit
that they were wrong about wokeness no
so they're going to find a way to Pivot
away from wokeness without empowering
anybody who got it right um because they
don't want to empower people who believe
things that they don't want to
face yeah and
um it's it's only going to get stupider
from here um like worse more more
creative tactics I think uh will
continue to come uh our way meaning like
at all of us and I guess I would just
return briefly to our discussion about
Hope and uh engaging with people both
strangers and not uh in ways that
suggest insinuate even if you will um a
lack of being fully on board with what
you were being told you must believe or
else you're not a good person uh because
really almost whatever it is um you know
not entirely but almost whatever it is
uh if you're being told you must believe
X and yes half the country believes y
but you must believe X or else you're
not a good person um there's a very good
chance that what is being done is an
attempt to control you as opposed to an
attempt uh to have you be fully realized
as a voting citizen of a republic
um and I would point out actually uh
quite some time ago we did an episode in
which we talked about the buzz saws that
were erected so that somebody who
stepped out of line could be shoved into
them I actually just went back to that
uh today and I was reminded that that
was one of the episodes that YouTube um
cut disappeared and uh Dem and
demonetized us over and that was the end
of our revenue from YouTube I did not
remember that but in any case the
argument was that there were certain
traps where you
know uh if you deviated from an official
protected narrative like vaccines are
inherently safe and effective so let me
I literally went back there today um and
I didn't realize it's was the episode
called DOD dodging the buzs saww it was
episode 82 it's still available on
Odyssey and presumably on Rumble I think
all of our back episodes or nope okay so
it's on Odyssey it's not on YouTube uh
and what one of the things we talked
about in there was The Interchange that
I had with our then 15-year-old son's
pediatrician and this was less than a
week after the eua had been granted to
give the MRNA vaccines to I think it was
like 12 to 17 year olds I don't remember
the younger um bracket but uh and we
Happ I happen to be taking Toby uh then
15 in for uh his uh just annual physical
to for camp and this doctor really hard
balled me in front of in front of Toby
um basically telling me in insinuating
again um but now worse than that saying
um that I was a bad mother and uh was
putting him at risk and uh he need and
furthermore that he needed to be allowed
to make his own decisions when I said no
he's not getting an mRNA vaccination he
doesn't need it um so I invited I
invited this doctor to have a private
conversation with our son I said I'm
happy to leave uh he rejected that uh
possibility and uh we certainly never
went back there um but I know that a lot
of people have had uh have had
experiences like that with people in
positions of power who say to them if
you don't do what I want you are a bad
person and I'm going to hurt you for it
and as much as possible we all need to
stand up to that um that is uh 100% true
just a little background on what that
episode was um that got I I think it's
actually perfect because the point is
the difference between having to make
that case as a mother defending your son
then versus now is all the difference in
the world because what they keep doing
is overplaying their hands on this these
industrial strength tactics and so the
fact is conspiracy theorist does not
carry the sting that it once did because
everybody has noticed oh my God there's
a lot of collusion going on so you know
the question isn't is that person a
conspiracy the the question is really
are they any good at it right are they
good at sorting the wheat from the chaff
right um likewise
antivaxer what does that even mean yeah
right they used to the slightest
hesitancy and they would call you an
antivaxer well if you don't have the
slightest hesitancy at this point you're
just not paying attention yeah right so
they are burning these things and that
means that our ability to have a
conversation in which you're not being
shoved into the buzz saww because the
buzz saww isn't even turned on anymore
right well no they're generating more
and more terms because they're burning
the old ones well right but the point is
okay so now they're they they're the
reactionary trap is a new one they are
now uh demonizing asking questions
they're demonizing doing your own
research right these people are
obviously out of control maniacs and we
can safely ignore it when they tell you
that asking questions is probably a sign
that you're not very smart right really
it's amazing it's amazing yeah yes yes
we can all right uh I think we're there
I think we'll talk about um uh more more
on safe and effective next time
safe and
effective was two words but we're we're
good actually no it suggests a uh a a
fork of the brand right you've got safe
and effective and you've got safe
and effective right is it actually safe
and effective or is it only safe and
effective ifar
yeah all right um we will be back on
Wednesday we'll be back in in not very
long and tomorrow we're going to do our
private Q&A on locals so uh seriously
join us there that'll be at 11:00 a.m.
Pacific uh two hours uh we've got the
link to ask questions is up there as
well um check out natur Natural
Selections where I write uh most weeks
and post essays about all sorts of
things what else um Hunter gathers guide
21st century is still out there doing
well it's about to be published in check
did I mention that already and we're
going to go to Prague for the book
launch that's be fun yeah um
let's see oh uh Discord uh Discord
server is um up and running and and and
great and you also continue to have very
good conversations at your
patreon we have our sponsors this week
once more we're mudwater paleo Valley
and Hillsdale College all of whom we
encourage you to go check out if uh any
of those products are uh up your alley
as it were and just a reminder that we
are supported by you really appreciate
you watching you uh chatting in the in
the watch party on locals sharing
talking with people about what you're
hearing what you disagree with what you
agree with all of that and
um and just a reminder to please join us
on Rumble and and locals if you if you
can it really helps yeah it does so
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]